what what do you think about what's
going on in iran today you know you see
the climate you see what's going on with
water you see them wanting the
revolution you see china came in and
signed a 25-year contract 400 billion
400 billion dollars what do you think
about what's going on iran today
my heart breaks for every young person
in iran you know um
i've seen this for so long you know the
problem with iran is it's been 40 plus
years of what's been going on and so
you see this i get people sending me
messages help us i got no i got nothing
you know and and unfortunately like i
was just in dubai recently and i'm
looking at dubai and i go geez dubai had
no natural resources and look at what
they've built in the past 30 40 years
and i go iran had all these resources
iran had and has so much
capacity of brain capacity i mean
iranian students were coming to stanford
university to the electrical engineering
phd program and their first year in the
phd program they were saying we've
already
studied all this stuff
in our undergrad and supposedly they
were like some of the top students and
then the problem is those guys come and
they stay why do they stay because they
want a better life and they can find
that here but they can't go back to iran
and have that better life because of the
government being oppressive the
government's oppressive against women
against homosexuals against baha'is
against a lot of people against young
people
and it's an unfortunate thing it really
is this totalitarian state and it breaks
my heart
and the question becomes well what do we
do right how do we help that how do we
help
that
come out of that now
one solution is to attack iran like you
did with iraq and get rid of the
leadership i personally i'm not an
advocate of war because i know that even
in iraq they lost i don't know how many
innocent iran iraqis died right so if
you did war with iran you'd lose half a
million a million people innocent people
would have to die i don't know
so on the one hand i go gosh that's not
the solution on the other hand i go
do you try diplomacy in which case a lot
of people are against it a lot of
iranian americans are against it because
they go diplomacy with this government
is giving them more power and more
strength
so i really don't know what the solution
is i'm hoping that the people of iran
are able to
lead what i hope is more of an evolution
than a revolution because
yes i want this government to go but i
don't want bloodshed like i mean there
is bloodshed already but i don't want it
to be so bad so in all honesty i just
try whenever i'm faced with any issues i
try to just show my support for the
people of iran currently there's
protests in uh uh who's estan because
there's no water the water's dirty yeah
um
and i i did uh on my instagram post i
did hey i'm i'm with the people of ira
of huzzastan and i want the media to
cover this
and i don't know what the future holds
but it just breaks my heart every time i
see the news coming out of iran so if
you like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you